another Google Cloud platform available  for developing and managing API proxies  is apogee Edge  unlike Cloud endpoints apogee Edge has a  specific focus on business problems like  rate limiting quotas and Analytics  in fact many apogee Edge users provide a  software service to other companies  back-end services for apogee Edge don't  have to be in Google cloud and as a  result Engineers also often use it to  take apart Legacy applications  so instead of replacing a large  important application in one move they  can use apogee Edge to peel off its  services individually  this allows them to stand up  microservices to implement each intern  until the Legacy application can finally  be retired